the five-second rule applies only at
home never in the restaurant
hi my name is Jed I am in pastry chef I
have been in food industry for about
five years now and just started working
at a French restaurant my name is Joe
Sasso I'm a chef at the moment I'm doing
pop-up dinners private events but coming
from San Francisco I was working at lazy
bear quince and number of other places
today I am going to share some insider
knowledge about the kitchen and food
industry about 99% of the time the
specials are actually special very
rarely in my experience that I've seen
is it like something left over or
something that they actually want to get
rid of most of the time there are
leftovers that are being repurposed so
that there's less food waste that
process is actually dependent on the
type of restaurant so the higher end the
restaurant you might have specials that
are there for creativity purposes you're
at a hole in the wall maybe there is a
chance that's special is something that
might be going by by tomorrow a lot of
food gets thrown out unfortunately even
like a little bit of a wilt on the
lettuce will get thrown out if it's like
a meat product and it'll probably be
repurposed for a special a lot of times
leftovers will go into family meal
that's what the staff will come together
and eat every day for lunch and rather
than it getting thrown away or serving
something that's not as fresh is best
possible product to the guests I will
eat it as cooks in the kitchen this is
the five-second rule apply the
five-second rule applies only at home
never in the restaurant it's actually
kind of embarrassing it depends on the
chef I don't think I've ever worked
anywhere where it's five-second rule
it's fine no it's like even a 1 second
rule it's dead probably not even for a
family meal in that case personally if
something drops on the floor I will toss
it but I have seen unfortunately some
chefs apply the five-second rule and if
I catch them on make them toss it
biggies customer pet peeves as a chef
are people to have allergies they don't
really know the details of their
allergies chefs hate it when customers
order steak well-done we will judge you
silently behind your back
well someone may say they cannot have
gluten they're allergic and then you ask
them if they're celiac and they have no
idea what that word means celiacs can't
have any trace amounts of gluten
sometimes someone may actually be a
celiac and I'll know it sometimes they
may just not want to eat gluten and say
they have an allergy when they really
don't I will never order a sandwich or a
burger you don't know how long that
burger meat has been sitting there even
a slight tinge of gray can still be
cooked and served to you certain salad I
will also not order unless I know that
it's like a seasonal vegetable I think
about what it's like in the kitchen back
there what makes the most sense to where
I'm at if I'm at an Italian restaurant
definitely going for the pasta if I'm at
a sushi restaurant I'm gonna want the
fresh fish kind of basing my orders on
where I'm at and making sure that I'm
ordering what the chef wants me to order
the joy I find in cooking is that it's
extremely therapeutic for me during the
times that it's stressful it's still
good kind of stress or you know if you
have a good team you're all working
together I love watching people's
reaction when they eat something that I
made there's like this sense of
nostalgia and you could immediately see
the memories coming back to them it may
be the last time they had that dish and
being able to see how that evoke a ssin
of emotion is incredibly joyful a lot of
work definitely goes into preparing your
food if you scarf it all up that's great
it's a compliment but also take some
time to ask or listen to the server
explain how the food was made where it
came from that's all part of the process
and it's not just behind the scenes it
should be for you as well
[Music]